- I'm happy to call him a friend,
Christian Siriano y'all, how you doing?
- Let me tell ya, huh, it's tough.
(laughing)
But, doing good, doing good.
- But the world has changed a bit,
since we last saw each other.
So how are you staying
sane in all of this?
- Yeah, I know, it's
been wild, it really has.
I mean, I live in New York,
which has really got hit pretty hard.
And it's a weird place,
to see everything closed
and it's kind of wild.
But I've been listening to the
governor kind of every day,
and there was such a shortage of things
and I was like, "Well,
maybe I can do something."
So that's kind of like why I
started just kinda pitching in.
I felt like maybe we could help.
And that was kind of it.
I just felt I couldn't sit
at home and do nothing.
- It's so devastating.
Like you're in a very devastating area
with this whole virus.
You know, it's really cool though.
I just wanted to say thank you
because you could just be
chillin' and doing nothing.
You know what I'm saying?
You could just be relaxing
and a lot of people are just like,
"Okay, I'm just gonna
stay safe and healthy."
And you heard a need for something,
and then used your talent
for this and it's super cool.
And I just wanted to say thank you
for doing that, for something.
Everybody doing something matters.
So what is the process
though, of making masks
'cause that's very different
from dresses and outfits?
(both laugh)
So I'm like,
yes, is that hard or is it weird?
- Its wild, it's like wild.
I mean I literally,
after I tweeted at the
governor and they responded,
they gave us kinda permission
to open my office with a small team.
And I realized my sewers
are like couture sewers
and now they're making masks.
It's quite monotonous work.
It's the same thing over and over again
and at the beginning we
were only making like white
and now I was like we
need to have some color.
I need something because we've
done like almost 15,000 masks
and you're like,
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- oh my gosh,
your eyes are bulging out
'cause it's the same thing.
And it's kind of hard,
to make quality control when you,
I didn't have a mask factory
and I just kinda turned it into one.
So it's kinda wild.
- Yeah, because there are like,
I guess specifications in what the mask
has to be able to do and the filtration.
Yeah, it's crazy.
We've looked at it too 'cause I quilt
and I've thought of doing
it with my five-year-old
on our little sewing machine here
just trying to make stuff and I was like,
"Oh gosh, I gotta figure
out all how to do that."
I was like, it's so crazy--
- You gotta thread the
machine and it's really hard.